the voice change that occurs in boys
when they develop and go through puberty
is a thickening of the vocal cords
that's Androgen dependent I have this
weird mutation I should have the same
voice I always had from when I was a
little kid my voice never actually
changed I have an androgen receptor
alteration okay fortunately for me like
doesn't cause any other issues but this
was my voice when I was 5 years old how
terrifying yeah they called me froggy
yeah it was kind of a joke I like the
kid on The Little Rascals that was
froggy but for most people they hit
puberty and then their voice changes
because of a thickening of the vocal
cords in any event when you train your
neck actually it does improve posture
and it actually changes the tamber of
your voice somewhat but for people who
speak a lot for a living podcasters
singers actors Etc you don't want to do
a lot of really heavy neck training
because it actually changes the way that
your jaw moves and the way that you
speak so you want to maintain healthy
air flow through this region